stranger things 3 is finally here along
with the Red Army parasitic sludge
monsters and more eighties references
and you can shake an ice cream scooper
at of course a TSS soldier is until your
find if you dig deeper here are just a
few of the small details you might have
missed in stranger things 3 one of the
earliest pop-culture references and
stranger things 3 comes with justin's
return to hawkins from summer camp
dustin tells everyone about his new
girlfriend suzy explaining that the only
way to contact her is this newly
constructed ham radio which he nicknamed
cerebro so it's a ham radio the Cadillac
of ham radios anyone familiar with
Marvel's x-men will know where Dustin
gets the name in comics and movies and
everything in between
cerebro is the device Professor X uses
to amplifies telepathic powers to find
other super-powered mutants with her
psychic abilities xi is a character in
stranger things most like Professor X I
wanna Clichy one of the few of the
series kids who isn't therefore
cerebro's and failing Dustin gets
everyone to agree to hype with him to
Hawkins tallest hill so they can set up
cerebro and contact Suzy but it's 11:00
and Mike Bale before they finish the
climb presumably to find a good spot to
make Oh Dustin cerebro ends up being a
pop culture reference standing on top of
another pop-culture reference he doesn't
use the name earlier when he leaves his
friends there but in the season finale
we learned Dustin has given a name to
the hill where he keeps cerebro
Weathertop he saves the name when Steve
takes him an Erica - cerebro
speaking it as if Steve should naturally
know what he means if your memory isn't
that grey or you're not a Tolkien fan
Weathertop is a ruin atop a hill in
junior Tolkien's Fellowship of the Ring
surely after they meet one another
Aragorn and the hobbits camp there on
their way to the elven land of Rivendell
is where the heroes are briefly
surrounded by the ring race and where
Frodo is stabbed in the arm by the
witch-king of Angmar and corrupted by
the undead warriors played as not only a
self-proclaimed nerd but a Dungeons &
Dragons player Justin is definitely
familiar with the Lord of the Rings
books hence the name he gives a hill and
even if he wasn't big on fantasy novels
he could certainly be a fan of the 1978
animated Lord of the Rings film in the
beginning of stranger things threes 4th
episode the sauna test max offers 11 one
of two comic books to read and those
specific issues seem to have been chosen
for a few reasons most obviously they're
accurate for the time Wonder Woman issue
300 into
Jiggs was released in 1985 the year in
which stranger things 3 was set while
green lantern issue 185 came out in 1984
both comics end with the reveal of a
villain reminiscent of the mind flayer
in green lantern issue 185 test pilot
Richard Davis and winningly flies a jet
into a giant black column and inside he
finds a clip so a mystically parasitic
supervillain known for controlling and
corrupting hosts just like the mind
flayer likewise Wonder Woman issue 326
end of the emergence of an Aztec guard
who's described as among other things
the god of the nocturnal sky the
embodiment of changed through conflicts
both concepts are powerfully present and
stranger things 3 particularly the
concept of change stranger things as
always wanted cinematic inspirations as
badges of honor and one particular
moment in season 3 proves the idea
pretty clearly when the scoop troupe
leaves the movie theater or trying to
escape the Russians we see a bunch of
1985 movies on the marquee including the
stuff return to Oz darrel flesh and
cocoon what happens in the stuff
residents of a small town or Lee tat son
of an addictive food sledge called well
the stuff turns out that the stuff is
actually a parasitic goop that takes
over people's brains and turns them into
mindless zombies before eventually
eating them yet like the movie as for
the other movies Return to Oz includes a
batch of bad guys called wheelers and
then they share with Nancy and Mike
wheeler daryl is about a secret
government science experiment to create
a childlike super soldier for the
military just like Elevens training
ledge features a journalist who
investigates a bigger story after his
editor tells him not so similar to
Nancy's pursuit of the story she hears
from mrs. Driscoll and cocoon is about a
bunch of aliens on earth disguised as
humans sound familiar
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
stranger things are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and at
the Bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]